welcome to episode 17 of the michaela
peterson podcast
i interviewed dan crenshaw this week dan
crenshaw is a congressman in the u.s
with the republican party
he's also graduated from harvard is a
former navy seal
the author of fortitude american
resilience in the era of outrage
and the podcast host of hold these
truths
this guy is tough he's been through some
real difficulties
difficulties is putting it lightly not
only did he actually become
a navy seal which is nearly impossible
but he lost an eye from an improvised
explosive device
and lost his mother as a child part of
the reason i wanted to speak with him
other than the fact that i think he's a
cool human is because
people who are that resilient and
determined are extremely rare
i think it's important to talk to them
and figure out how to be more like these
people
mental resiliency is really important to
survive life
i think if people could encompass some
of the attributes that dan has the world
would be a better place
people would be less cowardly at least i
was nervous about speaking with him and
got a side eye when i told him i don't
generally read the book of the people
i'm interviewing until after the podcast
which i hadn't clarified i find i can
ask questions
more people relate to that way however i
read his book first to prepare
i'm almost never nervous but this guy's
intense we discuss his background the
importance of having shame
we talk a lot about his experience in
the navy seals and becoming a seal
the importance of mental toughness his
experience
running for congress and more i hope you
enjoy the podcast
if you do remember to hit subscribe and
leave a review
[Music]
okay dan crenshaw welcome to my podcast
hey thanks for having me good to be with
you thank you
i i actually read your book to get
started i don't normally
read the books of people coming on the
podcast because then i can ask questions
that
i don't know the answer to but i was
super nervous having you on the podcast
and i wanted to be prepared so i read
the book
oh good well it definitely makes it
better um it's an easy read
i think um so thank you i don't know
it's a little bit
the first chapter is rough it was a bit
of a tear jerker
i thought oh oh oh about the
perspectives from
from darkness i guess um i don't know i
i i i've told the story so many times i
i i don't extract any like emotions
from it anymore um but yeah i mean
especially with the
the stories about my mother and kind of
you know it's it's a deeper discussion
about how to how to engage in
perspective
um and it's super applicable i think to
it's like
what's happening in today's pandemic era
uh where you know we we we sort of
forgotten how to
to deal with basic risk um and and i
think in a substantive way
and and i note this when i again this
this book was written about a year ago
at this point um and i make some
notes that i i'm i'm concerned by
by our society's ability um to deal with
some truly hard things
um because you know and i'm not saying
you should gain perspective by getting
blown up
uh certainly gave me a lot of
perspective on what's truly difficult
and what isn't you know going through
buds and l week yeah that's
that's kind of the point of hell week is
to establish a sense of perspective
establish your own limits
uh we can talk about what hell week is
if you'd like i guess
yeah yeah but the point is it's like
it's
the entire purpose is for you to push
past limits you really
really didn't think you had and
and and and then gain confidence from
that
and again i'm not i don't think
everybody should go that extreme
but even if you know you don't have to
hurt yourself or
engage in in tragedy uh to gain
perspective you can simply imagine it
and and we've we've actually pushed that
imagination out of our heads completely
um we we've we've ceased to to to
discover
perspective from our ancestors or from
even from our parents who live different
lives than we do
um you know objectively more difficult
lives
in many cases or you know or even
looking to others
who have had it worse i mean an honest
statement which i think is objectively
true no matter what
is no matter what you're going through
somebody else has gone through it
and they're performing better than you
are and if you think that way
and it's objectively true it has to be
objectively true just by by
probability's sake i think it's
objectively true
we would that that kind of stiffens your
spine a little bit
gives you a little encouragement and we
would say that all the time in buds
which was and the instructors would yell
at us as we're shivering and crying and
you know it's
so hard they'd be like thousands of
people have done this before you so get
over it
like you know that's uh okay that's good
to know
okay let's get into buds and hell week
and
for those who don't know who you are
maybe describe your background a little
bit okay
yeah so uh grew up here in houston um
my dad's in the oil and gas sector so we
moved around a lot i've i've lived
abroad
quite a bit throughout my life um so
that's and that gives me a different
sense of perspective as well
um i lost my mom to cancer when i was 10
and uh
which which hence there your comments
about the tear jerking
i think in that chapter and a
really strong woman and impossible
impossible not to again look back and
think this 35 year old woman with two
boys
was dying of cancer and yet never
complained i could i don't think i ever
heard it and if she did she wouldn't be
around her kids
um she just suffered through it pushed
through it fought through it for for
five years until she eventually
succumbed to that
um not long after that i think my dad
gave me a book on the seal teams
uh i can remember exactly how old i was
i i usually say around 11 or 12.
and uh it was by dick marcinko called
rogue warrior
and uh probably the first like seal to
really uh you know expose the seal teams
and write a bunch of books okay now it's
kind of like a common thing
but i was hooked i was hooked on that
sort of sense of adventure
um sense of elitism you know the the
warrior spirit all of it and that was
just my dream forever so
um you know every decision i made was
was
toward that goal um uh joined the navy
went through rotc which is basically a
scholarship program
uh that was commissioned as an officer
upon graduation
and um 2006 reported to buds which is
basic underwater demolition
seal training that's what that stands
for and six months of just a brutal
you know kick in the you know what and
it's it's
it's designed to weed out and filter out
the
the weak and the people who just can't
hack it and it's um sort of creates this
kind of microculture um you know we can
seals can spot each other
for miles away it's like it it's truly
remarkable it's just like a type and you
kind of know
um who each other are it's interesting
and i in in a sense that's form that's
formed in buds
and in a sense you were already that way
before you got there it's
that that's the filtration process i
think the screening process
uh i broke my leg my first time through
uh in the middle of hell week so i had
to start over again do that
um spent 10 10 10 years in the seal
teams oh yeah it's very fun
um i've had much more fun injuries than
that as it turns out
and uh and i'm very injury prone
so i was wounded in 2012 in afghanistan
that was my big wound
um but my god my platoon mates would
like uh would joke before i got
blown up that like because i was so
accident-prone
there's very dark humor in the military
so i was i was very accident prone
um i'd had my hand crushed by like a
vehicle rollover that i caused
um i i like it we were shooting on the
range one day and like a
bullets ricocheted and went through my
leg you know just like not big not a big
deal but like it was yeah not a big deal
but it was it was just like little
shards it really wasn't
um but it was it was just like how does
this happen it only happens to you
you know and it's like in a broken leg
um smashed my teeth on a skydive
once um it's just like funny things that
were annoying
um and those teeth came out again on
like a training off because my night
vision goggles like
slapped me in the face you know just i
didn't realize teeth could come out
twice
the same teeth well they're they're
crowns so uh
gotcha okay yeah um or
yeah or something like that they were
they were just repaired chips but in any
case they were gone again
so the and yeah so when i got blown up
everybody's like well we kind of feel
bad for making fun of you because they
would say like
you know when we're getting shot at the
bullets are just going to go around us
and hit dan
everybody laughs until i get blown up
and sounds so funny oh man
yeah and so and then i so left the steel
t i fought the navy
a while um says to stay in uh but
eventually had to succumb to the
sort of uh medical bureaucracy and could
not get a waiver to stay in the military
um you know because my vision issues
obviously
so 2016 left i went to harvard did my
masters in in public policy there
and uh with the intent of probably going
into you know policy
uh not necessarily politics and then you
know kind of overnight i was in politics
when uh my hometown congressman retired
and
just pointed out to me that hey why
don't you give it a shot and so
we did my wife moved into my parents
game room
uh started started a bad campaign not
even a good campaign and with you know
with three months to the election and
just went for it and uh
got into that runoff by by 155 votes
and uh and then the rest was history
i'm a congressman i guess yeah i should
say that too i'm a congressman for the
second district of texas yeah
uh okay what was the your book was very
interesting
um i think the parts i enjoyed was i
don't really know anything about
navy seals other than it's
i've heard it's the most difficult thing
to get into and
that's about what i know about it i know
they have everyone who
ends up being a seal has a wicked sense
of humor and that's all i've heard
about it uh so reading your book was
interesting to get kind of a perspective
uh i thought people listening would be
interested in
how you survive being thrown
out of a boat with your hands and your
legs
tied oh yeah um
it's tricky and i and i go into a lot of
detail in the book and
there's a reason i go into into this so
i enjoyed writing this book because
it's multidisciplinary um you know i've
got a concept that i'm trying to impart
on the reader
and in that case it's it's the concept
is be still
all right and i mean that somewhat
literally uh
it's a very you know you could also say
it's just count to ten before you react
it's it's that that's what i'm trying to
impart it's sort of a stoic sense of
of stillness and ability to think
through your actions and and not let
emotions drive your actions
i think that's an important attribute to
mental toughness i mean every single
chapter is supposed to be a tool for
mental toughness
and success and um what i point out is
is one of the one of the ways we teach
that in the seal teams because being
still is extremely important
uh if you you don't want people who are
prone to panic and
prone to emotional decision making
that's
that's a deadly attribute in the sale
teams so
and especially because we do so much
work in the water and the water is a
really great place to like
see who can hack it and who can't
because the water is
well you can't breathe in it so that's a
problem
um for a lot of people it's like
breathing is it's a requirement for life
as it turns out and we know that and so
when we're under it we're like i i don't
have my requirement for living
that's a problem and so this is what
makes people panic
when they're underwater um and
as it turns and one of the ways they
they start with that it gets much worse
that's drown proof and what you're
describing is drown proofing and that is
just as ridiculous as it sounds like how
can you prove somebody
from drowning um it gets much worse than
that actually during pool comp
which is a later phase in buds but we
start out with drown proofing because
it's actually relatively easy
as long as you're just calm and as long
as you can just go through the motions
and do it so
yeah you jump in the water with your
hands and feet tied behind your back
um your feet are tied together and your
hands are tied behind your back
so that seems like a very precarious
position to be in if you're trying to
um survive and swim yes it does and and
at first you just kind of bounce off the
bottom
you know i think a 15 foot pool you just
sort of you know we get comfortable
doing that
and that that takes some practice i mean
you can screw that up and then not be
able to get back up
um or or just start to get out of breath
because you screw up one jump
and and then you're really panicking and
that's that's not a good place to be in
but you eventually get the rhythm and
you get comfortable doing it but
but of course that's not that's not
being drown-proofed
because not all places that you could
potentially be thrown in the water at
with your hands and feet tied together
are 15-foot pools uh they might be a
hundred foot
ocean and so you have to learn to swim
and it turns out that's possible too and
so we just kind of
learned to like go through this kind of
weird dolphin kicking kind of motion
um and you can swim you can swim almost
indefinitely like that if you stay calm
but as soon as you
screw it up um you know and exhale too
much
or you know just you just get out of
that rhythm almost
exclusively because of panic um you're
screwed
so luckily in buds somebody will save
you but um
but and and and realistically this will
never happen in real life right
there's there's no actual situation
where this could possibly happen and
but but that's not the point um the
point is
can you learn to be still and uh yeah
still trying to do some drown proof
practicing you know maybe to this day
yeah fair um what percentage of people
who go through the
the buds make it like what percentages
drop
out it's about a 80 percent
dropout rate wow and that's a
combination
of just health issues um
failing certain evolutions you know you
you have to pass
swim times obstacle course times run
times
you have to pass pool comp you have to
pass the drown proofing thing i mean
some people just might not pass that and
then they're done
they don't necessarily quit but they
they just can't do it and
you know they're untrainable uh that's
what
we would say we can't you can't do these
simple things and we don't believe that
we can train you to be a seal
yeah uh and then but most just quit most
are ringing the bell which is a
which is you know it's a whole cultural
evolution in and of itself this bell is
carried around everywhere you're always
reminded that you can go quit
um you're reminded that there's there's
warm coffee and donuts waiting on the
other side of that
bell maybe a nice blanket uh and your
suffering will end
and so the instructors love to remind
you of this it's a it's a very
inviting um you know
inviting proposition and um that gets to
another chapter
called no plan b uh which is again in
layman's terms just means don't quit
uh it means it means live a life of
purpose and i attribute much more
meaning
to it than just just don't quit again
it's multi-disciplinary book so it's
yeah there's a lot of seal stuff in it
but
you know i i like to couple the seal
stories with some psychology i like to
couple that with some history with some
philosophy on stoicism
because it all connects and there's and
then some pop culture too
so i i hope the reader is remains
engaged throughout it because you'll be
talking about
you know ellen degeneres uh and
and you know jordan peterson
uh all in one chapter like it in israel
so it's
it's um it was a fun book to write
because of that yeah
um so i have to ask about your eye
because i asked my audience what they
wanted to know about and
i'm sure this is the question you get
the most but
from what i know from your book well i
read your book but my readers may not
have they should but they may not have
um it was a homemade bomb
right mm-hmm yeah yeah and an ied is an
improvised explosive device
um very very common uh in afghanistan
and
they're really the the real threat
depending on what part of afghanistan
you're in um
in some areas you're more likely to be
in a vicious firefight
that's just the type of fighters that
you're up against um in other areas the
you know taliban will
they calculate that it's probably more
effective to fight you with ieds and
just
corner your movement that way um and
they're right there
they're just vicious they're very cheap
mostly fertilizer compounds that
you know high explosives that are easy
to set off with a simple battery
um that's connected and that connection
happens when you know
two pieces of wood are just flattened
together
which happens when you step on it and
they could add a lot of explosives in
there that would probably kill you
but they their goal is um is more
nefarious than that it's it's to just
blow off your legs
and so normally it's rare that actually
somebody dies from those things now
um in my case i didn't step on it my
interpreter did
um a great guy named brockman he's
a smaller smaller guy and this was a
pretty big bomb
as it turns out and it was also
underneath very hard ground which
which matters to um because it just
creates more pressure and creates more
you know rock and solid things coming
through your body
and uh he immediately when he stepped on
it
he was responding to a call this was a
qrf mission
it was kind of a last minute mission um
not our normal type of planning
um which which maybe would have
prevented some of this
um you know sort of haphazard movement
that we that we were doing
but he was responding to a call ran
across it we hadn't really cleared this
courtyard yet and this was inside of a
home
um you know in a home in afghanistan in
the rural areas
means you know a mud wall
surrounding mud structures and uh it's
always like a courtyard thing
in the middle maybe a well and then
rooms off to the side and so you're
trying to clear these things of ieds is
difficult you only have a few
a few guys with metal detectors and it's
not it's not guaranteed that these metal
detectors even detect these things
because there's so little metal in them
um but so he hit it blew up kind of felt
like i just got hit by a truck
um and i didn't you know i kind of
intuited what had happened right away
and i could hear him
moaning i felt my legs right away um
and so i knew i hadn't hit it but i knew
i'd been hit and
he lost all four limbs right away and
he later died and i was hit with the
blast
so just right right just because i was
right next to him
and all that hard rock and metal because
i think they packed it with metal too a
bunch of screws and bolts and things and
i know that because i found them and
they were in my hands
later um and you know the the the damage
to my
good eye um was from you know copper
shards that had shot through it so
because of the size
my eye can see out of is is very badly
damaged too
i don't know i've cataract and iris
doesn't work so
special contacts that i wear to be able
to see anything um
and uh so i was conscious throughout the
whole thing about 45 minutes later the
medevac helicopter
came and knocked me out as soon as you
know they see my condition there
and uh i didn't wake up for five days or
so and i think that's when the real
nightmare started
um because i could i walked away from
the blast
um adrenaline still pumping and all but
uh but the real
the real horror started about five days
later when i actually woke up
yeah well what what got me like that's
the part of your book that got me
as i've had injuries nothing like
getting
both eyes blasted but i've had joints
replaced and
the healing process isn't pleasant um so
that part got me
because you describe you described
having multiple surgeries
with all the doctors telling you that
you're doomed anyway and then being told
you have to lay face down for six weeks
if you want it to work but there's no
guarantee it'll works
is that right yeah yeah and the horror
is more when you don't know if you're
going to see again so that in and of
itself is kind of mentally devastating
and uh you know the there's a lot of
veterans who
immediately lost both eyes and like
that's a
blindness is a very serious thing um i i
can't
i can't say especially especially
traumatic blindness that just happens
it's um it's one thing to lose it
gradually it's one thing to be born with
it it's all bad
but um you know all of a sudden
everything goes black
it's a very devastating thing and
there's some just i met veterans who
lost their sight completely and their
ability to overcome adversity is just
unbelievable
it's incredible incredibly strong people
um so but the the thing about but i was
blind for a while so i in a sense i
i did have that traumatic blindness and
what happens there is kind of like a
ghost limb
phenomenon where you still see
but you're not really seeing and so um
my brain was just was sending images to
my
as if i was seeing it and it was that
was the horror that was the nightmare
because it was quite
literally living in a nightmare um and i
was
mostly seeing afghanistan so i couldn't
escape afghanistan
i knew i was not delusional i was
hallucinating but i was not delusional
i knew i was in landstuhl at the time um
about to be transported to to bethesda
maryland
but i would just see afghanistan so i
like i knew i had some buddies who came
with me to stay with me in the hospital
in germany they kind of flew in from a
different deployment
and um so yeah you know i was not
crazy like i knew what everything was
and i couldn't move either because my
body by that time was totally swollen
and
you know it's like i said i had bolts
and stuff shooting through my body
everywhere no permanent damage from
those things but um
but at the time was quite painful um but
you know pain is one thing i think the
not knowing about whether you'll see
again that's
that's that's the part that's horrible
um you know injuries injuries where you
don't know that what the outcome is
going to be
yeah that's that's truly bad um because
yeah
i could think of some recovery uh
surgeries that i've had
remember i'm accident prone i forgot
that i broke my jaw a year before i got
blown up too
i forgot to mention that one like that's
a crappy recovery
you know because your jaw's wired shut
um
and a few years later uh
about every two to three years i have a
bad injury that's kind of like my my
habit
um i'm overdue for one which scares the
hell out of me
um so uh and i've been doing a lot of
skydiving recently
so we're like yeah skydiving with one
eye is fun
uh it just adds a little it adds a bit
of extra um adrenaline to the
one eye and the contact lens yeah
yeah i mean you wear glasses you know
it's fine um this contact lenses
i mean you can't get it out like i need
a special tool to get it out it's a very
specific specific thing so skydiving is
not a problem
landing is is different because landing
requires a decent sense of depth
perception
which i just don't have so i have to use
other kind of uh visual
uh tools to to land but i still land
pretty well
um oh what i would say like a couple
years ago i i tore my tendon
my tendon off the bone skiing um so i
was i like
i was going down this like double black
and
some isis was there so i was fighting
isis
in the mountains of vale and um i won
but i
but i tore my tendon i didn't fall or
anything that's not what happened it was
it was isis
so just just for the record
yeah or it might have fallen might have
fallen pointed out that's a terrible
recovery so
i was like yeah that's a worst recovery
than
them literally ripping the eye out of my
head you know like that's
it was actually wow that's saying
something yeah
yeah i guess it doesn't last longer you
got to do the
physical therapy to get your arm back up
and running um
so you know it's all relative it's all
real yeah
yeah okay so you've been you've been
through
you've been through some things and you
go over those in detail in your book
um why on earth did you
decide to become a congressman i always
associate i associate politicians with
people who
didn't become scientists or something
and want attention like
that so thanks no no
but then you were a seal so that that
puts you in a different category
yeah i minored in physics so does that
make me a scientist
no probably not yeah i mean most people
haven't i had to take
uh two years of physics and it was
easier than calculus but it was not easy
so i think that counts for something
yeah yeah the differential equations
that that's what got me i did not do
well in different potential equations
physics eventually just becomes proving
theorems and that's when i was like okay
i'm done
because i i'm not a math major i don't
that's why i minored and didn't major
i feel like that's why where calculus
starts yeah i was miserable yeah
i was um but i but i love the concepts
in physics
um you know anyway that's not what you
asked uh oh yeah why did we go with
congressman um
so impact i i think is the answer so i i
i left the military wanting to still
make an impact mostly through policy
that just seems like the most reasonable
pathway
um politics was in the back of my mind
but there was no pathway to politics uh
i'm not rich i don't know any rich
people and uh
there was no not an obvious opportunity
until there was an obvious opportunity
and still didn't know any rich people
but
but i have a sense of of what's required
to win a campaign and it's actually
pretty simple to distill you have to get
people to know who you are and then get
people to like you
that's how to win that's how to win a
campaign um
and so the but the reason you even get
into it
is a a few different reasons
impact across a wide variety of issues
if you just want to impact one issue
then start a non-profit for that one
issue or get into a policy and go a
think tank and like
do that one issue you know work for a
member of congress and focus on that one
issue if that's what you care about
that would be my suggestion it's it's um
i i find politicians that run on a
single issue and that's all they care
about i find them to be inadequate i
find them to be not very well-rounded
and i find them to be activists and i
don't think you should run for
office if you're an activist and um
you know i'll put my i'm gonna be a
little partisan now and say that i
the thing about the left and democrats
is that they're mostly
activists their entire philosophy of
governance is activism
that's not a that's not a governing
philosophy this is why i'm a
conservatives and this gets to why i ran
because i believe deeply in the
principles of conservatism i believe
these are the things that work
and the how matters quite a bit and i
don't think that conservatives are
making a good argument for conservatism
or the reasons we believe in the
policies that we believe in
we haven't been making a good argument
for a very long time so i saw a uh
an imbalance there that i needed that i
felt i needed to fix
and so i worked very hard on
framing the arguments for for why this
works for why this is the proper
governing philosophy
the reason you should elect politicians
is because of how they will solve
problems
you know and politicians know that they
can get elected by telling you what they
want to do
for you that's a very you know but
that's that's
effectively the same thing as buying off
your vote
because they're not telling you how
they're going to do it we can all say
hey we want you know
a better environment we want we want to
fix poverty we want better health care
for people
and that's fine but if you're not
explaining to people
how you're going to do it and what your
limiting principles are
to solve those problems you're you're
not a politician you're an activist
and we have way too many activists in
politics and so of
counter that problem is was a was a big
reason
i got involved are there any democrats
that you actually respect and admire
my friends yeah for sure um
there's good people there's good
liberals still
um but my fear among the democrat party
is that the liberals are trampled over
by the leftists
and that's a that's a dangerous thing
but but i certainly have friends
um that i i think are really good people
i think they're really wrong about some
of their policies but but the but the
mark of a good person too is like hey we
just want to get like this objective
done
and so so i i grant that to liberals
quite a bit like
the things they want are not bad again i
just named a few but whatever cleaner
environment
you know a better path to prosperity for
people impoverished
better healthcare these are laudable
goals um
values to uphold but but you know we
disagree vastly on how to get there and
i want to get there in a more
sustainable way
they want a program that gives it to us
right now
and that's you know it's nonsense
um so but but again it doesn't mean
they're bad people
um my worry among the left is
that that there's much darker
undercurrents in leftism derived from
marxism
and that's overtaking the liberal the
more liberal
predisposition um and and classical
liberalism is being trampled over
in the sense of of adhering to values of
free debate honest debate
rational thinking logic based thinking
uh free speech
you know the protection of inalienable
rights these are liberal values
but it's only conservatives that
actually defend them now and that that's
what worries me
a great deal marxist taking over sounds
like a conspiracy theory
oh yeah well yeah your dad talks about
it a lot he knows
you know um but it's true sounded more
like
yeah it's it's true it sounded more like
a conspiracy theory in 2016 than it does
now
right no that's true um yeah
yeah and that's that's a key insight
actually conservatives have been talking
about this stuff for a very long time
we know the history of progressives way
better than progressives do
okay we can trace it back to like when
did when did they start thinking like
identitarians
when did when did you know when did
progressivism become
a bad word when did that you know we
know that progressives
were were enamored with fascism at a
certain point until fascism
became nazism there's a lot of
interesting history that americans don't
know about the origins of progressivism
it's not a good origin it's very bad
it's very anti-constitutional
it's anti-inalienable rights um you know
it's progress for the sake of progress
but mostly for the sake of power
and and to gain that power
there's a quick path to it and it's the
politics of resentment
and this is where marxism i think comes
in it's it's tearing down the other
and marxism is group of politics in the
sense of you know
the the capitalist versus the the
proletariat
you know attacking the one percent you
know this is more the classical bernie
sanders
um but even bernie sanders wasn't always
an identitarian kind of socialist he was
uh
that's that's a new thing he sort of
just embraced it because he's had to
um but but that identity politics came
into
into play around the 60s because and i
think the reasoning is pretty
interesting so from the
so-called new left back in the 60s they
were like well marxism isn't going to
work because these damn middle class
people are just too happy
so you're not going to get them to
revolt um because they have it
you know okay so we've got to make them
feel like they don't have it okay and we
also have to build a coalition
based on identity whether you know
gender and race
mostly um to and and show them how
oppressed they are
and have them rise up for the marxist
revolution so it's all part of the same
thread
of what is really fundamentally just
resentment politics
resent somebody else and vote for the
politician who promises you power
over that other group i think that's the
best way to define identity politics
it's groupon group power
and it's um it's just very dangerous and
divisive
and uh so and it's got its roots and
marxism and we see it
see it fully today on display and yeah
we we would say these things for years
but you're right it's sounded like
conspiracy because again americans could
just kind of look around for the most
part
and say i don't think i see what you're
saying
you know i i think things seem okay
right now
and uh you know why why are you so
against helping out some disenfranchised
groups like why can't we just before
that more and more and more
and more and more and more and um
and our answer is because it will erupt
into this
this highly charged situation
and now we see that and i hope that
people see that
i still think a lot don't um yeah or if
they do they don't
they they're not tracking the origins of
it correctly
they're blaming trump i mean that's
frankly the reality
because he's an easy thing to blame now
there's no logical
consistency there and i think people are
thinking oh these people are just rising
up because he's a horrible
fascist you know and it's like that's
why they're just freedom fighters
no antifa's not freedom fighters um
they're they're first of all they
existed before trump um
and you know and their history goes back
a long way and people need to understand
that
okay so as someone who's been injured
and had to go through
rough things how do you stop yourself
from
becoming resentful from the experiences
you've had
and how do you put your experiences
towards something more useful like how
do you stop
how do you stop someone from becoming
one of the people that marches in the
street resentfully
because they have some difficulty that
they're blaming on other people how do
you stop yourself from blaming things on
others and take responsibility for that
yeah you have to consciously tell
yourself a story of
being a victor instead of a victim so
there's no secret to that
and it's not easy um and i would never
claim that all these the lessons that i
point out in the book are like it
doesn't mean that i am
the pinnacle of these lessons this is
not true like i
i fail at these lessons constantly this
this book is a
is a higher um it's something to live up
to
and so you know i i do my best but i
definitely fail
um so that's the first realization but
and that kind of gets into the one
chapter where i go into the notion of
shame
a lot which is basically just
understanding what you've done wrong
there's a cultural element to shame too
that we could get into which is kind of
interesting but
but to answer your question it is simple
it is very simple but also very
difficult it is simply telling yourself
the right narrative
you know we live by narratives we live
by stories and our behavior and our
our psyche i think changes radically
depending on what stories we tell
ourselves it's very easy to tell a story
of being a victim
and and being oppressed even in unfair
situations have happened to me many many
times throughout my life
um i've lost many many friends who that
we did not deserve
to lose and their families did not
deserve to lose them
um i lost my mother
um you know i didn't get into the
schools that i thought i should get into
and not get the jobs that i thought i
should get when
less qualified people did get in to
schools or jobs
and i saw this happen it's a is that an
injustice
perhaps or i you know i don't know
and this is kind of a thing it's like
even if it is an injustice and it's a
very clear one
you derive no benefit from living liv
living in that kind of victimhood state
and so
because i don't want to dismiss people's
true injustices that occur these things
do occur
um you know racism is a real thing that
can happen discrimination is a real
thing that can happen
but the problem with our society is that
we that we assume all discrepancies
and all i guess all disparities are a
direct result of somebody oppressing
another
that's objectively not true it's just
not true
it can't be true it's impossible for it
to be true um
but we've we started to assume that
constantly instead of
again just using some deductive
reasoning and saying
did i not get that job because i didn't
do well in the interview
like is that a possibility possibly they
was looking for somebody else
who maybe even just was different than
me
you know like and and maybe i could have
done better uh answering that specific
question i mean you know put it on
yourself so that you actually have
control
yeah instead of removing agency from
yourself
and um and removing personal
responsibility
from yourself which is uh it's kind of
like a warm blanket
feels good it's their fault it's not my
fault i'm still great
but it's useless this is a useless mind
state of mind to be in
and it's also very disempowering it sets
you up for for
grievance and bitterness and um and
ultimately uh
failure so tell yourself the right story
which is the name of chapter nine the
stories we tell ourselves
yeah i think that was that was a great
chapter too that's really important
i had somewhat of an experience with an
autoimmune disorder and people telling
me
you know anyone who's had ill health is
you might be stuck with that forever and
there's nothing you can do about it
which actually isn't true for many
health problems that you wouldn't know
but it does it takes all the power out
of your hands
so telling yourself the right story is
important partly because
that means you can do something about
whatever difficulty you're experiencing
if it's completely out of your hands
it's completely somebody else's fault
you're stuck like that forever like what
kind of story is that to live
no it's it's um it's like it's a prison
it's a prison and we have a lot and it's
it's become
this is another theme of the book that
has become
elevated so we used to look down on
people who who thought that way
and we told them you need to think
differently it's the right way to think
is
is is to overcome adversity not to dwell
on it
and um so going back to the beginning of
the book there's a chapter called you
know who is your hero and this gets into
hero archetypes
uh quite a bit this is this is i really
like this chapter because i like
psychology
and um and this is this is important i
think a lot of these insights probably
too because your dad talks about hero
archetypes too he's very influential on
me
um and so this
this gets to the to the problem we have
where we've we've flipped hero
archetypes in our society
and we've elevated victimhood as a
heroic attribute and
and diminished um
you know our heroes um and our hero
archetypes
you know the person who overcomes
adversity the person who is strong and
and shows good judgments in this this
kind of
that explains a lot of behavior that
you're seeing
where you know people are looking for
that extra benefit i see in the veteran
community quite a bit
it's very it's very frustrating for me
um
we see people looking for that extra you
know 10
disability rating 20 how do i get to 100
you know these are people there's
nothing there's nothing 100 disabled
about them even in the least
and um you know why why is and people
cheer that on
and that's that's wrong especially for
veterans you shouldn't think that way
um it's it explains why there's so many
um
hate crime hoaxes there's so many far
more
hoaxes than there are i think people
have actually mapped this out in the
numbers
far more hoaxes than there are actual
crimes
because it there's something about being
the victim
that that people celebrate and
it's just it's just wrong and again why
do they do it there's deeper reasonings
goes back to what we're talking about
before
it's for power because that's how you
gain power
um in this day and age but it's it's a
very dangerous chain reaction
it's a dangerous trend um it just pits
people against each other in a really
bad way
yeah it seems like it's kind of a
response right the the me too movement
was a response to
certain people not being believed when
they should have been believed and then
we just completely flipped it into okay
believe
everybody which just screws over people
on the other side
seems like some of it's a a response
yeah a big overreaction yeah yeah and
then
of course it's a good example where what
what is a
uncontroversial statement of you know
and movement in me too
or should should be uncontroversial and
righteous um
it did did disintegrate into an attack
on due process itself
which is um which is how it which is an
injustice
a a serious injustice you know there's
there's multiple ways to define
justice um one is infringing on the life
liberty or property of somebody else
so obviously somebody was sexually
assaulted that's an injustice committed
against them
but if that didn't happen and you then
undermine due process that is also an
injustice
the problem with the word justice
recently and again the problem i have
with the left
is they use the word often because it's
a good word it's something we all agree
on but they redefined it
and to them justice means power it means
power over somebody else
that's their form of justice and that
that gets to the
this gets to the slogan that is often
screamed in the streets these days no
justice no peace
that's a very carefully thought out
slogan in my in my estimation that's uh
it means but it doesn't mean what they
think it means or that it doesn't mean
what they say it means
it means no power for us no peace so
it's a hostage situation
and uh i think that's playing out quite
clearly
yeah definitely uh okay at the very
beginning of the podcast you mentioned
shame and in your book you talk about
part of the thing that
navy seals have which i imagine is
actually just extremely high
conscientiousness
i would assume it's um kind of a shame
if you don't do your best or if you fail
at something and you mentioned that
people possibly aren't feeling as much
shame for
failure as they should be so could you
delve into that a little bit
yeah um so it's as it pertains to the
seal teams
um you know we shame each other
a lot uh self-critique's an important
part of becoming better
that's also a that's also a western
attribute and if you're in the
special operations community and you've
trained with a lot of different special
operations
um teams around the world
you start to note that western
civilization and self-critique are
closely intertwined whereas you know you
work in asian or middle eastern cultures
they can't self-critique and in fact
they
yeah they have threatened to murder us
uh
for for shaming them in public it's
actually it's actually quite scary
it's it's it's you know because you have
the green on blue issue in afghanistan
which means an afghan soldier kills a us
soldier and
sometimes that's that's not sometimes
that's because they're like a taliban
informant
um or spy or just an insurgent and
sometimes it's because you shamed them
sometimes it's because you disrespected
them
and in our guy we have to like reign our
guys back sometimes
because you know anyway but
you're like hey you can't yell at them
you got to be super nice to them pull
them aside very like privately
and make them feel good but like south
koreans are the same way
um they don't want to self-critique they
uh they they wanna they wanna hit the
same target and training over and over
again do it perfectly for the four-star
general
and then give each other high fives like
they did a good job we would we don't
train like that
we train to failure um we make ourselves
fail and then we shame each other about
how we reacted to that failure and
that's why we're so elite that's what
makes us better the europeans are the
similar um
do it the same and i would say south
american countries depending like
colombians are really good
um uh mexicans as well so you know it's
western culture it's um just part of it
and we can deal with it and um it's it's
important and it's important to do and
so that's the seal type i'm not saying
everybody you would we can't shame
everybody the way we do in the seal
teams
not everybody can take that and i get
that that's okay everybody's it's
different um you know we don't do that
in the office uh the way i would have
done in the platoon space
but the um but but the
but you have to know what's right or
wrong and you have to hold people
accountable
and um again i almost wish i'd written
this book
now because there's just so many more
examples right now
in this day and age and you know talking
about the shame thing it's like
we're excusing mobs and rioters and and
making sure that they
they don't feel even the slightest sense
of shame for looting stores
right we're excusing it you have black
lives matter
leaders in chicago saying no no it's
good that they looted that's reparations
so we're we're flipping right and wrong
on its head completely again
irrational thinking logic based thinking
is completely thrown out the window
that's kind of the point of again of a
marxist movement
it is kind of the point to to uh to make
you believe that two plus two equals
five that this is
this this is kind of deeply entrenched
in their and their sort of
post-modernist philosophy
the point is confusion and um and then
and then sort of bullying um by way of
moralizing
uh against one another so it's it's it's
real problematic and it but it all goes
back to this just basic sense of shame
like is what you're doing wrong
you know and and and note it and note it
in the small ways
is what i talk about in the book so
there's obviously the big ways like
you know the seal teams and then there's
the small ways like
are you that person at the you know it's
a fast food restaurant
who doesn't throw their food away um
after you're done and put the tray back
where it's supposed to be
and maybe even wipe down the table
especially a coronavirus
era you know where like cleanliness is
is like a
really important thing in the pandemic
era um
are you that person that just doesn't do
it you know and then
are you expecting who else is going to
do it expecting the the
people who work there with minimum wage
to do it you know
they will but do you feel bad about that
you should
you know it's just simple just a simple
sense of shame um
it's just important for growth um and
it's it's important for you to just
become your better self
uh and all these lessons kind of pile up
on top of each other because
again one of the first lessons was you
know imagine yourself to be your best
hero or your heroic self
you you imagine you imagine your best
hero attributes and you strive to be
that that's the hero that's why it's an
archetype and not a person that's why
i don't suggest that you you look
towards a person that you want to
emulate you look towards an archetype
and um
it's an important distinction and uh
but to be that you have to know what
right or wrong is and you and you have
to know when you're screwing up and you
have to just be conscious you just be
conscious about it that's it
it's not that hard it's very basic stuff
i added a lot of like
extra storytelling to it and like an
extra an
extra research because i i just enjoy
kind of the academic side of it
but mostly it's these are very very
basic things that i think we've just
failed to teach our
our kids and our culture about about how
to just be tougher
in this world well
where can people find you online
everywhere um we got my own podcast
and it's called hold these truths
i would love to cross post this but we
can't i'm not let's talk about my book
on my podcast because it's an official
podcast so that's why
um the uh uh instagram is a great place
to find me dan crenshaw tx um i have
multiple accounts on twitter
dan crenshaw tx and rept and crenshaw
and the same on facebook
so any of the above um generally just
searching my name will will get you what
you want
great well thank you very much for
coming on remember me
when you're president i will i will
can't forget
yeah thanks for having me
you